[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
hello von einer Doppelfolge in die
nächste hier ist Tatort Deutschland und
ich bin Toni Heyer und ich bin Mirco
Kasimir und nachdem wir in der letzten
Ausgabe über den Bombenanschlag auf das
Oktoberfest gesprochen haben bleiben wir
in München reisen aber noch ein paar
Jahre zurück genau nämlich in den Sommer
1972 in diesem Jahr ist 10 Wochen lang
der Song Mami blue an der Spitze der
Charts
[Musik]
aber auch der zeichentrickhund WUM mit
seinem Meisterwerk ich wünsche mir eine
Miezekatze
ich wünsche mir eine kleine Miezekatze
für mein Wochenendhaus der schenkt dich
eine Luftmatratze und eine Spielzeugmaus
[Musik]
am 26 August beginnen mit viel Tamtam
und viel Elan die 20 Olympischen
Sommerspiele die Nation marschieren in
bunten Uniformen und Trachten in das
neugebaute Stadion ein
[Musik]
[Applaus]
München 26 August 1972 frühmorgens in
wenigen Stunden beginnt hier das größte
sportfest der Welt ziehen unter diesem
Dach Athleten von 122 Nationen
[Musik]
DDR
[Applaus]
[Musik]
Japan
das war die offizielle Dokumentation zu
den Spielen an diesem 26 August an
niemand was für eine Tragödie bevorsteht
wenige Tage später sterben 11
israelische Sportler und ein deutscher
Polizist sowie fünf palästinensische
Geiselnehmer in Israel ist das bis heute
ein Trauma sagt bildreporterin Antonia
Jamin die in Israel als Tochter eines
Israelis und einer deutschen aufwuchs
also auf Hebräisch nennt man das die
Münchener Katastrophe oder das Münchener
Massaker und das ist halt eine
israelische Nationaltrainer dass ich 27
Jahre nach dem Holocaust auf deutschen
Boden
ereignete und ich kann nur sagen dass
bis heute Israel und Israelis das Gefühl
haben dass sie damals im Stich gelassen
worden dass damals diese 11 Sportler
einfach ihrem Tun überlassen wurden und
niemand ihn geholfen hat und die
Hoffnung war natürlich dass Deutschland
irgendwas macht und es hat es halt nicht
gemacht aber wie gesagt erstmal gehen
alle davon aus dass Tage der Freude
bevorstehen
Westdeutschland will bei diesen
Olympischen Spielen sein neues
freundliches und demokratisches Gesicht
zeigen dazu gehört die extra komplett
neu gebaute Sportanlage mitten in
München entworfen vom Architekten
Günther Benisch und sein Team heute
kennt wirklich jeder dieser Anlage mit
dem zeltartigen Dach damals schwärmt die
Kulturwelt mit dem Ensemble zu den
Olympischen Spielen 1972 hat sich die
junge Bundesrepublik Deutschland als
eine freie Gesellschaft einen gebauten
Ausdruck gegeben der weltweit große
Anerkennung erfahren hat das brillante
am Olympiapark ist die herausragende
Architektur des 75.000 Quadratmeter
großen zeltdachs und dessen Einbettung
in eine wunderbar bewegte Parklandschaft
den renaturierten Olympiapark
unter dem transparenten mit Plexiglas
bedeckten Dach befinden sich das
Olympiastadion die Olympiahalle und die
Olympia Schwimmhalle übrigens ist auch
das Design dieser spielesensationell das
kommt vom Grafiker uttelaicher und macht
ihn weltberühmt da ist die schnittige
sportlerbekleidung das Logo mit dem
runden Kranz aus strahlen und die
einfachen Piktogramme für die Sportarten
aber während sich die Sportler ab dem 26
August ihre Wettkämpfe liefern steht im
Hintergrund eine Truppe von Terroristen
bereit die sich ebenfalls schon lange
auf dieses Event vorbereitet hat
acht Palästinenser angeworben und
angeleitet vom Chef der Kampfgruppe
schwarzer September about der hatte
zeitweise in Berlin gelebt und galt
deshalb als Deutschland Kenner aber Daut
hat die Einreise seine acht Kämpfer
organisiert die Unterbringung geregelt
und sie mit Waffen versorgt am Morgen
bis 5 september 1972 führt er seine
Truppe noch zum Zaun des Olympischen
Dorfes dort gibt er ihn den Staat Befehl
für die Mission
Monteur der Post sehen die Männer
morgens um 4:10 Uhr über den Zaun am
Nordrand des Geländes klettern aber sie
denken dass es sich um heimkehrende
Sportler handelt die Männer gehen im
Grau der Dämmerung zielstrebig zum
Bungalow der israelischen
Olympia-Mannschaft checken die Lage und
dringen um 4:35 Uhr dort ein
den Terroristen wurde es aber auch
ehrlich gesagt ziemlich leicht gemacht
denn die Sicherheitsbedingungen während
der Spiele waren extra locker gehalten
um für eine angenehme Atmosphäre zu
sorgen für Olympia waren insgesamt 4.000
Polizisten abgestellt aber sie liefen
unbewaffnet herum und trugen statt
Polizeiuniform bunte modische Anzüge im
Bungalow der Israelis Hausnummer 31 des
Olympischen Dorfes da bringen die
Attentäter 11 Menschen in ihre Gewalt
David Marc Berger
cfriedmann
Josef Romano andre spitzer
Gerd Schoer Max Slavin
Jakow Springer und Mosche Weinberg bei
diesem Überfall im Morgengrauen
herrschen Chaos und nackte Panik einige
hier nicht genannte Sportler entkommen
nämlich darunter der Mannschaftsleiter
Schuhe lightin zwei von ihnen dagegen
werden in dem gewill sofort erschossen
Mosche Weinberg und Josef Romano Romano
hätte trotz seiner Schusswunden noch
gerettet werden können aber weil kein
Arzt zu ihm gelassen wird verblutet er
innerhalb von zwei Stunden Zeuge dieses
Dramas wird der israelische Gier
schauladani
bildreporterin Antonia Jamin hat ihn
mehrfach getroffen und kennt seine ganz
besondere Geschichte also schaue Dani
ist sowohl ein Überlebende des holocus
als auch ein Überlebender der
Olympischen Spielen in München ich kenne
schaue schon ein paar gute Jahre ich
habe ihn vor ein paar Jahre sogar in
Budapest gedreht das ist die Stadt in
der ist ja auch im Ghetto war er hatte
da ein Marathon und ich dachte mir ich
drehe ihn einfach und mache mit ihm mit
er rennt ja nicht er läuft ja ich habe
mich sehr getäuscht weil ich konnte
einfach nicht mitmachen ich habe ihn am
Anfang gedreht und dann muss ich am Ziel
auf ihn warten also der ist wirklich
schaue dann ist einzelartig er ist durch
und durch Israeli und wie sehr viele
Holocaust du Überlebende will er der
Welt aber auch sich selbst zeigen dass
er gewonnen hat dass er die Nazis
besiegt hat aber dass er auch jeden
besiegen kann der Israel schaden will
Charlie ist zwar nicht unter denen die
gleich um 4:35 Uhr überfallen werden bei
ihm beginnt der Schrecken eine Stunde
später wie er sich in einer Doku mit
Antonia für Bild TV erinnert
ich hatte national stolz ich dachte wir
zeigen der Welt und Deutschland dass wir
obwohl sie versucht haben uns zu
eliminieren hier sind und in der Lage
sind und der ganzen Welt auf dem
gleichen Niveau wie alle Weltsportler zu
stellen
gegen halb sechs Uhr morgens weckte man
mich und dann sagte mir man hat Moni ein
Sportler in der Delegation ermordet ohne
viel nachzudenken steckte ich meine Füße
in die Sportschuhe ich bin immer noch im
Pyjama aber gehe zu Haustür und öffnet
sie
rechts von mir am Eingang zur Wohnung
Nummer eins steht jemand er trägt eine
Sturmhaube und schaut gerade aus vor ihm
stehen vier Wachleute des Olympischen
Dorfes alle unbewaffnet und den
pastellfarbener Kleidung unter ihnen
eine Frau sie bittet den maskierten dem
Roten Kreuz zu erlauben einzutreten und
jemanden zu helfen sie sagte ihm er
solle menschlich sein er antwortet die
Juden sind auch nicht menschlich nein
mein Charakter wurde halt durch den
Holocaust geprägt
ich habe so viel durchgemacht und ich
denke dass ich ein Stück weit immun
geworden bin
schon um 5:03 Uhr geht bei der Polizei
ein erster Anruf der Geiselnehmer ein um
5:21 Uhr ein richtiger Notruf
bevor Polizei und Krankenwagen
eintreffen legen Terroristen die Leiche
von Mosche Weinberg vor das Gebäude um
6:40 Uhr treffen zwei Funktionäre am
Tatort ein der Chef des Olympischen
Dorfes Walter Tröger und willi Daume der
Präsident des Deutschen Olympischen
Komitees bis 8 Uhr wird daraus eine
kleine Vollversammlung von wichtigen
Leuten oder denen die sich dafür halten
vor Ort sind nämlich auch noch
Bundesinnenminister Hans-Dietrich
Genscher der bayerische Innenminister
Bruno Marc Münchens Ex-Bürgermeister
Hans Jochen Vogel und der Münchner
Polizeipräsident Manfred Schreiber die
Terroristen stellen ein erstes Ultimatum
bis 12 Uhr mittags am gleichen Tag
sollen in Israel mehr als 200
inhaftierte Palästinenser freilassen
werden sowie die deutschen RAF
Terroristen Andreas
sitzen sie drohen die Geiseln sofort zu
erschießen falls die Polizei das Haus
stürmt israel lehnt es umgehend strickt
ab den Forderung der Terroristen
nachzukommen wenn wir nachgeben wird
sich kein Israeli irgendwo auf der Welt
noch seines Lebens sicher fühlen erklärt
Premierministerin goldair
deutsche Medien berichten live aus dem
olympischen Dorf und so können die
Geiselnehmer die Aktion der
Sicherheitskräfte im Fernsehen
mitverfolgen die Terroristen ändern ihre
Strategie und fordern ungehindert mit
den Geiseln in die ägyptische Hauptstadt
Kairo auszufliegen das Ultimatum wird
schließlich bis 15 Uhr verlängert
verschiedene Funktionäre bieten sich zum
Austausch für die Geiseln an vergeblich
übrigens sportlich gesehen gehen die
spiele schon seit Stunden einfach weiter
so als sei nichts passiert erst um 15:38
Uhr werden die Wettkämpfe schließlich
abgebrochen was aber weiter geht das ist
ein beispielloser Nervenkrieg das
Ultimatum wird noch mal verlängert die
Geiselnehmer zeigen sich bewaffnet auf
dem Balkon Vertreter der Arabischen Liga
versuchen sich als Vermittler die
Geiselnehmer die beobachten alles im
Fernsehen also ihr müsst euch das mal
vorstellen
die Polizei will das Haus Stimmen
vergisst aber den Terroristen vorher den
Strom abzustellen so dass die alles am
Bildschirm in Echtzeit mitverfolgen
können gegen Abend zeichnet sich ab wie
die Lage aufgelöst werden kann die
palästinensischen Geiselnehmer sollen
zusammen mit ihren israelischen Geiseln
nach Kairo ausgeflogen werden vor dem
Transport zum Flughafen sollen die
Scharfschützen aus dem olympischen Dorf
abgezogen werden der damalige
Innenminister Genscher darf in den
Bungalow Nummer 31 und dort mit den
Geiseln sprechen sie sind mit dem Flug
nach Ägypten einverstanden was
Geiselnehmer Geiseln und die
Öffentlichkeit aber nicht wissen ein
Flug nach Kairo der ist noch gar nicht
ausgemacht
Bundeskanzler Willy Brandt verhandelt
mit der ägyptischen Regierung darüber ob
die mit einem Flug der Kampfgruppe
schwarzer september in die Hauptstadt
des Landes einverstanden wäre
zeitgleich checkt die Polizei wie man
die Geiseln auf dem Weg zum Flughafen
Fürstenfeldbruck bei München befreien
könnte
gegen 21 Uhr lässt der ägyptische
Ministerpräsident Azize aus Kairo
ausrichten wir lassen das Flugzeug nicht
ins Land also bereiten die
Sicherheitskräfte in Fürstenfeldbruck
eine Befreiung vor während in München
die Terroristen und ihre Geiseln in
Hubschrauber steigen erst jetzt sehen
Beamte vor Ort dass sie es mit acht
Geiselnehmer zu tun haben aber das
Funken sie nicht an die Kollegen am
Flughafen durch dort steht eine Boeing
727 der Lufthansa bereit als die
Hubschrauber aus München landen nimmt
das Unheil seinen Lauf denn das
befreiungsteam fährt ohne Plan einfach
auf Sicht eigentlich sollten Beamte sich
im Flieger als personalausgeben und die
Terroristen dann überwältigen aber sie
leben dem Plan abhalten ihn für zu
gefährlich und steigen einfach wieder
aus
um 22:29 Uhr landen die Hubschrauber bei
Flutlicht in Fürstenfeldbruck bis zu
diesem Zeitpunkt wurde immer nur von
fünf anstatt der tatsächlichen acht
Geiselnehmer ausgegangen deswegen
befanden sich auch nur fünf
Scharfschützen auf dem Dach des
Flughafengebäudes und dem Rollfeld
die Palästinenser und ihre Geiseln
steigen aus den Hubschraubern und gehen
nach und nach in die Lufthansa-Maschine
mittendrin bricht das totale Chaos aus
zwei Terroristen die schon in der
Maschine waren lassen sich gegen 22.40
wieder auf der Treppe blicken sie haben
bemerkt dass gar kein Personal im
Flieger ist und wollen zurück zu den
Hubschraubern da eröffnen Scharfschützen
das Feuer sie treffen einen der Männer
der andere der sich Isa nennt und als
Anführer gilt entkommt es beginnt ein
wilder Schusswechsel bei dem unter
anderem die Funkanlage des Flughafens
getroffen wird erschwerend kommt hinzu
dass die aufgestellten Scheinwerfer alle
blenden und scharfe Schatten erzeugen
und die Terroristen so leicht eine
Deckung suchen können bei dieser ersten
Eskalation werden vier Terroristen
getroffen und ein Polizist getötet
die Terroristen bleiben unterdessen mit
den Geiseln in den beiden Hubschraubern
und beraten wie sie mit der Lage umgehen
sollen
währenddessen fordert die Polizei
weitere Einsatzkräfte an um einen neuen
Befreiungsversuch zu Unternehmen nicht
nur auf dem Flughafengelände ist die
Lage chaotisch auch die politische
Führung ist spätestens jetzt völlig
kopflos ein Mitarbeiter des Nationalen
Olympischen Komitees tritt vor die
Presse am Flughafen und behauptet alle
israelischen Geiseln sein befreit worden
was leider eine Falschmeldung ist
als sie Terroristen die Verstärkung der
Polizei sehen die Panzerwagen da
eskalieren sie die Lage final einer
ihrer Männer in Hubschrauber 1 schießt
auf die dortigen Geisel springt dann
raus und wirft eine Handgranate in die
Kabine kurz darauf bringen seine
Mittäter auch in Hubschrauber 2 alle
Geiseln um die Scharfschützen der
Polizei wiederum schalten alle
Terroristen aus
nach dem letzten Schuss um 1:30 Uhr sind
alle Geiselnehmer und alle Geiseln sowie
der Polizist Anton fliegenbauer tot
Deutschland zeigt nicht mehr sein
fröhliches Gesicht
Deutschlands blickt in einen Abgrund im
Land das während der Shoa 6 Millionen
Juden ermordet hat waren die Sportler
Israels 1972 nicht sicher die
Sicherheitskräfte versagten beim Schutz
des Olympischen Dorfes beim Erstellen
eines Plans und beim Einsatz am
Flughafen wie ist mit den Olympischen
Spielen weiterging was aus der
Terrorgruppe schwarzer september wurde
und wie Deutschland ein zweites Mal
versagte das hört ihr in der nächsten
Folge hier bei Tatort Deutschland bis
dahin eure Toni und euer Mirko